go visit your farmers you know that's
number one is I had no idea the
Catskills were as beautiful as they were
and I no idea that their farms just not
even a two hour drive north you know and
growing great vegetables potatoes corn
tomatoes and list goes on and on and on
plus plus some you know animals
livestock and it was it's amazing to get
out of city and to see that and
something that you appreciate a whole
lot more
I wish that there was a larger market
where vendors could go sort of like off
of Essex Street but like I wish it was
like enclosed or not enclosed like a
dedicated place where people could buy
their stuff all the time not like
chelsea market but I don't know like I
think they're still a disconnect people
don't really know where their food is
coming from even from the greenmarket
you know they don't realize well this
person actually harvested this stuff and
then drove you know was up has been up
for like 24 hours getting his truck
packed and is driving in and they're not
wealthy and they're doing it for you
know because this is what they don't
matter